y en el is alcedo el reagrupamiento de
hogares de mujeres víctimas de violencia
con jugar acaba de lanzar una campaña de
acción y concientización de qué se trata
esta campaña que se llama violencia
conyugal o violencia doméstica en todos
sus estados en todas sus facetas en una
serie de vídeos para sensibilizar con
respecto a la violencia doméstica sobre
todo para enviar el mensaje que la
violencia doméstica no solamente es
violencia física
entonces que esta violencia puede
afectar a cualquier mujer de cualquier
estatus social de cualquier origen
cultural queremos red
repetir el hecho de que la violencia
conyugal llega a todas partes pero
también tenemos un objetivo específico
nos dimos cuenta que a nivel de impacto
graves de la violencia los muchos casos
de violencia con impactos graves a nivel
criminal son para las mujeres entre 18 y
25 años entonces queremos ir a hacer
civilizar estas personas porque a veces
nos reconocen que están viviendo la vida
está condenada
y cuál es la situación de la violencia
conyugal aquí se cuenta con datos que
puedan cuantificar el fenómeno en el
país o en la provincia en particular
mire yo tengo datos con respecto a
seguridad pública que son los datos
compilados como por los crímenes que
conoce conocido como ex crimen o sea que
las mujeres denunciaron y quisieron un
proceso concreto sin embargo estos datos
que no identifican a todas las mujeres
que viven la violencia con mitad y que
nos denuncian a nivel del sistema de
justicia al cosas no es un dato real
sino los datos que han sido
criminalizado yo les doy un ejemplo el
80% de las víctimas de violencia con
villar son mujeres todavía a nivel del
sistema jurídico en ese con en ese grupo
el 97 concepto de las víctimas
en un contexto de violencia con metal
todavía son mujeres entonces podemos ver
que estas estadísticas son muy elevadas
cada día pero el nivel de estas mujeres
precisamente viven todavía la violencia
confinada algunas estadísticas dicen que
todavía tres sobre cada cuatro mujeres
viven un tipo de violencia cuando
hablamos del tipo de violencia puede ser
violencia física psicológica económica
religiosa hay muchas formas o
estrategias que utilizan los hombres un
contexto de violencia conyugal para
controlar la comida para
y privarla de sus derechos entonces esto
es lo que hace que nosotros en esta
campaña queremos hablar no solamente de
la violencia física
se suele hablar de la violencia conyugal
ligada a la cuestión de la pobreza por
lo general se señala que en países de
bajo poder adquisitivo o de pobreza
directamente existen más o existe un
nivel de violencia conyugal superior al
de otras naciones en el caso de canadá y
en el caso de la provincia de québec en
particular hablamos de territorios con
un alto poder adquisitivo con un alto
nivel de vida son el canadá un país
desarrollado es que ve una provincia
desarrollada cuáles serían aquí las
causales si es que se puede hablar en
esos términos de esta violencia conyugal
y eso es lo que hemos incluso las
naciones unidas lo ha retenido como el
análisis de la violencia computaron de
la violencia hacia las mujeres
la pobreza no es la razón de la
violencia esto es un factor agravante el
consumo de drogas un problema de salud
son factores agravantes de la violencia
con cuidado pero a la raíz hay un
problema social que es el problema de la
desigualdad de género o sea hay hay
estereotipos que están fijados como el
hombre es el jefe de la caja el hombre
el que manda en el que lleva los
pantalones y ese tipo de creencias se ha
arraigado por mucho tiempo y en ciertos
países donde no está mujeres no tienen
acceso a alquilar su otro apartamento no
tiene el dinero el pobre no puede salir
de la violencia pero no necesariamente
es porque son pobres que viven la
violencia nosotros todos los hombres
pobres que está en la violencia
o sea que conmigo no sé tenemos que
tener claro que la pobreza del consumo
de droga de alcohol y los problemas de
salud puede ser físico mental son
factores agravantes pero no son las
causas de la violencia las causas de la
violencia y las diferencias con respecto
a el posicionamiento social de la mujer
o del hombre que si tiene el derecho que
si le impedimos tener derecho del hombre
continuó a tener una vida como de
soltera como de activo incluso después
del matrimonio pero la mujer que tiene
que quedar guardada para poder respetar
el respirar dado josé ángel y usted ya
lo dijo en algún momento hace unos
instantes hizo referencia que la
violencia conyugal no se refiere
exclusivamente a la violencia física
sino también a otros medios volvamos un
poco sobre este tema de que otros medios
hablamos de contra manera se expresa la
violencia conyugal aquí
y justamente quedan en el punto del
objetivo de la campaña los vídeos son
son vídeos que van a representar un
poquito cuáles son los otros tipos de
violencia porque nos sentimos en un
medio donde lo han pegado pero yo tengo
miedo a mí a mi cónyuge oa mi novio o
tengo incluso miedo no estoy bien en la
relación pero tengo miedo de irme porque
me ha mal estado y creo que de verdad
puede ser peligroso irme entonces
tenemos que reconocer otras estrategias
de control
y deshacer algunos mitos por ejemplo
cuando dicen a él es tan celoso me
quiere elevación a ningún otro hombre me
puedes ver eso es una manera de
controlar controlar a las mujeres por
ejemplo dice no es tu familia te mete
cosas en la cabeza yo no quiero que
sigas viendo a tu familia o a tus amigas
pues empiezan a explorarla cuando un
hombre pierre a una mujer aislada puede
tener más control le quita el acceso al
dinero al control del presupuesto
familiar a veces le rompe la ropa para
que no pueda salir las que están en el
medio de trabajo para que la bolsa de
trabajo y no pueda tener acceso
económico entonces todo eso son
estrategias y prácticas para evitarle
que se vaya y el miedo es una de las
razones más grandes de una mujer siente
que tiene miedo de su polvo y así nunca
le haya pegado pero por lo menos sabe
que podría hacer cajas y sabemos que
muchas veces no tenemos las puertas
defendernos entonces todo esas
estrategias hacer que la mujer no puede
irse que la mujer tenga miedo que la
mujer no tengan los medios económicos
para poder instalarse hacer su vida por
eso la importancia que las mujeres sepan
que deben utilizar los servicios de las
casas de albergue y las internas de la
trabajadora de la casa de albergue
pueden ayudar más a construir un
escenario de protección para servir de
la relación y el ciclo de la amnesia de
una manera seguro pero entonces es
importante de pedir ayuda es importante
estar acompañada en todo el proceso así
no tenga que ir a la casa de albergue a
los hogares y vivir en la moda después
de bing los servicios sin necesariamente
ir directamente viviremos más
no lo habíamos hablado previamente pero
si no ocurre en este momento supongo que
esta posibilidad de recurrir al pedido
de ayuda debe ser particularmente
importante en casos específicos como el
de las mujeres autóctonas por un lado y
las mujeres inmigrantes por el otro es
cierto que cuando le hablaba de factores
agravantes la cuestión de las nuevas
autóctonas es con un factor agravante
ellos viven otras
otras violencias sistémicas que hace
particularmente anclada a las mujeres
inmigrantes también a veces las mujeres
inmigrantes recientes de cuando han
llegado hace poco al país que no conocen
los servicios que no conocen sus
derechos que tienen miedo que pedir
ayuda que tiene miedo desde el punto de
vista de las personas de la sociedad que
la recibió entonces cuando no tenemos
esos conocimientos y no sabemos
exactamente qué es lo que estamos
viviendo
si no hablan el idioma es muy difícil
comunicarse por supuesto tienen que
saber si no habla ni el francés el
inglés llamar una casa de albergue oa
deseo es de violencia conquistar van a
conseguirle a alguien que hable ese
idioma para conseguir de alguien que
pueda ayudarlo entonces puede ser
bueno de saber que si es un factor de
vulnerabilidad que aumenta el peligro y
el aislamiento de la mujer más que está
aislada más difíciles
tienen que saber que es posible de salir
de la violencia incluso extender el
control incluso siendo inmigrante
y en él dice nuestra conversación previa
si nos referíamos al tema legal y
decíamos de no entrar puntualmente a
abordar la ley porque para eso haría
falta un abogado que conociera
puntillosamente las disposiciones
legales pero en todo caso las
herramientas legales de las que
disponemos actualmente son suficientes
para contrarrestar para hacer frente
para poner coto al fenómeno de la
violencia conyugal
es importante entender que aparte de la
ley hay implicación personal y de otras
personas de la sociedad pero existen
las infracciones que se cometan en
contexto de violencia codificada y que
no respeten el la ley civil la ley
criminal del código civil y criminal
puede ser juzgada pero de eso depende de
que la mujer esté bien acompañada por
poder seguir el proceso desde la
denuncia a la policía hasta ir a la
corte como sabemos y eso no solamente
aquí hay mucho que hacer con respecto a
cuando una víctima tiene que demostrar
que es una víctima a nivel del aparato
de justicia entonces por eso decimos en
el inventario no solamente que las leyes
existan pero que esa mujer pueda ser
acompañada e informada de una manera
adecuada de tener una trabajadora de una
casa de albert y que le acompañe tener
un abogado como usted dice en la
compacto
cada provincia en canadá tiene planes
diferentes y tiene
un conjunto de servicios diferentes
particularmente en la provincia de
québec desde el año 95 existe una
política para luchar contra la violencia
política y tal vez 5 años hay una
hay un plan de acción que se renueva y
que va a tratar de ir a gustar todas las
acciones que no se han logrado para
ayudar a terminar la violencia con
dignidad pero como sabemos todas esas
acciones no tienen un impacto como lo
esperábamos porque ya hace 40 años o más
que me estaban trabajando con esos leyes
y todavía la estadística de violencia
ante el amo de la violencia combinada
son enormes incluso a nivel criminal a
nivel estadísticas que han sido juzgadas
sin tener las estadísticas reales de la
muerte que no denuncia entonces sabemos
que hay mucho que hacer con respecto el
vecino que ve que una mujer está
viviendo que escucha que pueda denunciar
llamar a la policía el hermano que sepa
que él
el esposo sus cuñados demasiado
controlador no deja salir a la hermana
todo eso que pueda intervenir de una
manera adecuada alguna manera adecuada
si no sabemos cómo llamamos una casa del
bebé para preguntarle en nuestra
compañía que nos digan cuál es la mejor
manera para que se asegure tario para la
víctima porque a veces involucrarse sin
saber cómo puede poner a la víctima en
mayor peligro entonces es importante de
informarse antes de actuar para que el
escenario de protección de las mujeres y
los niños que son muy afectados por la
violencia con césar se ha planificado de
una manera servida
por último john ellis en pocos días más
el 6 de diciembre se cumple un nuevo
aniversario de la denominada masacre o
matanza de la escuela politécnica de
montreal cuando 14 mujeres perdieron la
vida
o por efecto de las balas de un atacante
solitario que fue motivado por su odio a
las mujeres y al movimiento feminista o
las reivindicaciones del feminismo en
general qué reflexión le merece a usted
de este hecho y cómo se enmarca esto en
esta campaña
hacemos un llamado a la sociedad en
general tenemos involucrarnos
personalmente yo creo que yo lo he
repetido varias veces durante nuestra
conversación
en el momento que tomemos en cuenta
y el hecho de decir al muchachito varón
cuando se pone bravo agua o mira tiene
el carácter del papá que si va a ser
bravo este va a ser un verdadero macho
lo estaba enviando el mensaje que lo que
está haciendo está correcto y en el
momento que la niñita que está haciendo
una rabia igual que hizo el niño le
vamos a hacer o no la niña no aceleres
con mi amor tienes que probar te como
una princesita ya le estamos
condicionando a que ella no tiene que
reivindicar sus derechos que no tiene
que nombrar cuando está brava que no
tiene que defenderse y lo contrario le
estamos lidiando como un mensaje al
varón entonces importante desde que
estás pequeñito nosotros como padres
como miembros de la familia como destino
como profesor de invertirlos en la
educación de nuestros niños para que las
desigualdades que quiero y los roles que
le estamos dando y los mensajes que le
estamos enviando como que el hombre
tiene que derecho a todo y en la niña
tiene que seguir tener miedo de no salir
para que no la violen de no contestar
para que no le peguen de nuevo y
entonces
a la reivindicación de sus derechos
entonces es una cuestión de educación
más y más estamos trabajando en las
escuelas para sensibilizar al
respeto en las relaciones amorosas de
los jóvenes y queremos continuar
justamente hablar con los jóvenes porque
seguido las niñas y los adolescentes
dicen o no ahora yo tengo los mismos
derechos que los varones hoy estudiar lo
que yo quiera puedo hacer el deporte que
quiera pero en las relaciones amorosas
hay mucha violencia muchísima entonces
queremos hacerles identificar la
violencia donde que sea muy grave y
aquel antes de que tenga el agresor el
control absoluto y que la víctima tenga
miedo de defenderse para no tener
consecuencias peores y de imagen más
vemos que los jóvenes están denunciando
la violencia cosa que creemos es una
buena inversión de continuar a trabajar
con los niños y con los adolescentes con
las personas jóvenes que no reconocen
las otras manifestaciones de violencia
como la violencia psicológica el control
en inmigración
sexual obligará a tener relaciones
cuando no tenemos ganas todos esos
acciones o estrategias comparten la
violencia en un contexto de relación
amorosa
y dice al 0 muchas gracias por esta
entrevista con radio canadá
internacional
el placer es para mí estoy contenta de
poder enviar el mensaje a las personas
de habla hispana que están y que van a
poder tener la información y poder
compartirlas con sus familiares con sus
destinos con sus amigos